hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück zu
easy german heute aus dresden
hallo leute wir sind wieder unterwegs
heute mit den teilnehmern unserer easy
german summer school und wir haben heute
mann aus druck gemacht nach dresden
aber wir haben kein tor guide hier wir
werden die menschen fragen an den
verschiedensten sehenswürdigkeiten was
man hier ansehen kann und was das ist
los geht's und jetzt muss kann alles
noch mal machen weil ich nicht dabei war
glaubst du können sie uns sagen wo wir
hier sind
im brief und zwinger und können sie uns
etwas über diesen ort erzählen kleiner
zeit von profis augusts des starken in
sachsen haben die das baut ihr errichten
lassen
komplett das ganze ensemble ist mehr
oder weniger unter seiner zeit mit
entstanden jetzt befinden sich glaube
ich noch mal sehen hier tritt
technikmuseum so was wir kommen leider
nicht aus dresden und kennen uns hier
auch überhaupt nicht aus ja also ich
weiß auch nicht so viel über den ort
ehrlich gesagt aber es ist der zwinger
es ist also eines der bedeutendsten
hauptwerke hier in dresden
und es ist im barock stil erbaut
das erkennt man glaube ich auch an den
fenstern die diesen rundbogen haben und
hier war früher eine orangerie
das ist so eine sammlung ansammlung von
exotischen pflanzen und wir waren
irgendwie galerien drin und
ausstellungen
ja das ist auf jeden fall barockbau stil
vom august den starken gebaut genauso
wie auch die semperoper ist jetzt die
dritte oder vierte version der tempo
und in dem zwinger kann man auf jeden
fall die gemäldegalerie die
kunstsammlungen anschauen
martin kannst du schon einen dresden.de
ist mein erstes mal tatsächlich einst
auch ja schön dass wir das zusammen
erleben werden und was weißt du über
dresden ist eine stadt in ostdeutschland
bekannt in deutschland für die oper für
die semperoper jetzt in und für die
frauenkirche jährigen auch noch hin
genau ich glaube das sind die nächsten
beiden stationen
aber das wissen ja unsere summer school
teilnehmer nicht die müssen das dann
herausfinden an welchen orten wir uns
befinden und für die geschichte ist und
ich glaube aber lernen wir noch was ich
auch schon kurz bei wikipedia lesen
sehen
nein das kann nicht sein das war pokémon
go können sie mir etwas erzählen über
dieses ort für diese sorgt ja also dass
die
die semperoper hier in dresden und eines
der schönsten opern häuser deutschland
und was passiert hier drin das haus und
hof raus der dresdner staatskapelle
ich glaube sie spielen auch regelmäßig
auf aber für details da müssen wir uns
mal den den dem plan heraussuchen um zu
sehen wann finden in die veranstaltung
statt werten gerade eine führung gehabt
hat uns sehr gut gefallen ist ein
schönes haus auch von innen von außen
sehr schön von innen aber auch sehr
schön sagen sind sowohl wir gerade sind
im stallhof zu tricksen befinden wir uns
hier nur eines der markantesten und am
liebsten auch fotomotive unter touristen
aber auch touristen selbst was ist hier
passiert hier sind ritterliche turniere
durchgeführt wurden hat zum beispiel im
stechen wie oben sind noch die beiden
säulen wo ein seil gespannt war
dringender mit und hatte an reiter weise
versuchen mit einem stange diesen ring
zu treffen oder man hat sich vom pferd
geschubst aber solche können sie sich
auf ein mittelalterverein die dann
entsprechend dann mit stumpfen waffen
den gegner vom pferd holen wollten nicht
immer glimpflich abgegangen sind auch
tödliche unfälle passiert also auswahl
nicht ohne phantasie eben zugehört ich
habe mich um unsere summer school gäste
gekümmert heißt das hier passiert ist
sagt ritter turniere auf dem platz und
tier jagten so richtig mit seinem weißen
die sind so geritten und da muss nicht
mit so einer langen land fehlen so einen
ring stehen sie eine besondere anekdote
irgendwas was nach ganz stadt bekanntes
nach also weniger bekannt sein sohn
christian der zweites damals beim
turnier dann vom pferd gestiegen
glühende hitze hat so ein großes maß
bier hinter gekippt und ist gleich vor
der stelle tot umgefallen war 27 jahre
ist also es war ziemlich dumm gelaufen
sah ich mal so erfahrt ihr übrigens 31
jahre schon dort also trunksucht häuser
zu alkoholismus damals also trunksucht
genannt die hauptaussagen weshalb die
beiden ziemlich früh verstorben an
dieser stelle auch mit 27
27 die anekdote war der der das hier
aufgebaut hat und sein sohn sind beide
um die 30
durch alkoholismus ums leben gekommen
ist
die zugesagte dumm gelaufen gut dass wir
noch leben
ein ritterturnier in der hitze vom pferd
gestiegen hat ein maß wir gelernt und
ist sofort tot umgefallen 1
gut es gibt schlimmere tode
wo sind wir jetzt jetzt schafft in
neumarkt in dresden wo und was wissen
sie über die frauenkirche her
die frauenkirche ja so einiges in der
stadtführer die wurde von august den
starken errichtet wurde im krieg
zerstört dann zu ddr-zeiten als mahnmal
gegen krieg und zerstörung stehen lassen
den 90ern wieder aufgebaut 2005 geweiht
das wort man kann damit anfangen dass
die schwarzen steine die man hier an der
frauenkirche sieht die original steine
von der kirche von vor 300 jahren sind
und die ganzen hellen steine sind die 9
die man vor ungefähr 20 jahren hier
angebracht hat als die kirche neu gebaut
wurde es also 2005 war sie ja dann
fertig gestellt ja wir sind jetzt hier
auf der elbe einem der größten flüsse
deutschlands der geht hier durch dresden
in den hohen norden bis nach hamburg und
dann in die nordsee auf der linke seite
seht ihr die neustadt von dresden und
auf der rechten seite die altstadt
liebe leute das war unsere episode aus
dresden wir hoffen es hat euch gefallen
und ihr habt ein paar neue ort entdeckt
wenn ihr in deutschland seit kommt
unbedingt mal nach dresden es lohnt sich
ein besuch
und wenn ihr lust habt dann kommt
natürlich auch zu unserer the german
summer kokskohle ist man auch martin
hallo hallo und besuchte uns dann könnt
ihr wie die anderen hier mit uns deutsch
lernen und auch ausflüge machen im
ganzen land bis bald an christus
abonniert unbedingt easy german hier
unten und unterstützt sonst werdet
mitglied bei katrin da bekommt ihr ganz
viele extras zu unserer heutigen episode
zum deutsch lernen
martin